Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Like I would love to watch Tyron Woodley versus Damien Maia.
Love it.
I would love to watch it.
That would be that.
That to me is maybe one of the most interesting fights on,
on the horizon for me so far,
Damien Maia has been able to take down wrestlers that exact 70.
He's been able to take them all down.
Yeah.
Like easy and just the beautiful technique and uh,
but can you do that to Woodley and you've got to go?
No.
You got to go through the storm,
the storm of fucking meteors coming.
Your way that Woodley drops on you.
Cause he's the most dangerous in that first round.
When you're,
you're trying to take him down,
you're closing the distance on them and you haven't like figured out how fast he
is yet because he's not,
he doesn't just hit hard.
He's fucking fast.
I saw some,
uh,
just rumor,
I'm sure,
but a Brisbane was talking about it.
Him and Woodley a grand a Superfight at one 80.
Really?
Bisbing being Woodley real.
When did they agree to this?
Uh,
I was talking to my brothers sworn he was like,
you see Woodley and Bisbing want to do that catch weight at one 80.
I'm like,
that's an interesting fight.
First of all convincing,
make that healthy.
That's what I was thinking.
Cause five's a tough cut for,
I remember when he used to fight 2:05 PM two oh five.
Yup.
Wow,
that's an interesting fight.
Well I think what,
what would they want is that big payday?
He's like,
let's not,
yeah,
I mean he's campaigning for it.
Look at this.
Mike Bisbee and Tyrone Woodley agree to catch weight.
This is legit.
So it's just happened today on the Internet.
What is the name of the,
um,
the Internet low kick,
mma.com.
Interesting.
That's Bisbing through Instagram and shirt.
Very interesting.
So a gangster weight as Chael Sonnen calls it.
Yeah,
I like it.
But like to your point,
Woodley just wants a big fight for lucrative payday.
That's all he wants.
The biggest name possible to get paid.
Yeah.
Smart.
That's the name of the game and the Anderson back.
Uh,
and that has been still been calling for a rematch with a Bisbing to cause his
fight with Bisbing was so fucking close in England.
He feels like he beat him.
That was one of the craziest situations.
Several years.
He hits him with that flying neat.
Kaos awesome.
I mean,
Bisping was out.
He went out,
he dropped and Anderson does a walk off K on they go,
Eh,
not so quick.
It was so weird.
So weird.
Nope.
Oh why does that make get a video of that?
Cause remember Bisbing takes a break cause his mouthpiece falls out and he's
like talking to the ref and Anderson goes,
oh that's right.
That's right.
He,
he was trying to get the referees at tension and Anderson Flying Nita and the
ref like coming in to stop it than Ashton did that flying knee.
That's why the ref was like,
hold up.
No,
that doesn't look at that.
That's very weird.
Cities being boxed his fucking face off.
Like he's saying something.
It's herb dean.
Look,
he's like right there.
Right there.
Boom.
Oh Jesus.
That was also the end of the round two,
right?
Yeah.
Oh my God,
Jesus,
look at this again.
He's like,
Hey,
let me get my mouth PC.
Oh Shit.
Oh boy.
So look at this.
Boom.
That is such a crazy drop to the way you get hit,
you know,
thrown the knee regardless whether he looked to the side or not,
I think he would have thrown it regardless.
And it wasn't like Bisbing put his hands down.
He looked over,
but he was still covered up.
Here's the crazy thing that I think he was a little distracted there for sure.
Here's the crazy thing.
Bisbing comes back and wins that fucking fight face off.
How'd you in that actually comes out that,
I think that was the third round,
right?
He comes out that fourth round and his face off crazy.
Like a fucking kangaroo crazy recovery.
That means unbeliefs.
Cardiovert insane.
Yeah,
because most people get hit like that.
That's it,
man.
I mean,
his body shut off and he dropped.
No,
the power would give us a second and we're back,
but partially blind in one eye or completely.
Partially.
Yeah.
But he could still see,
he can see enough where they let him fight.
Mm.
Yeah.
I mean he does those dye tests.
They have to do I test.
Apparently what they did is they put some kind of oil in his eye and that oil
like protects his retina somehow or another.
And that's why it looks so crazy.
And once he's done fighting,
then they'll fix it.
But the problem is like if he gets it fixed now and then he goes and fights
again and tears it even worse.
And then the other thing is,
the more time he waits,
the more advanced all the stem cells shit is getting.
Like they write,
they brought someone's vision back with stem cells applying guy.
Someone was blind and they injected stem cells in this guy's eye and brought his
vision back there.
And that's today,
2017 what's it going to be like five,
six,
seven years down the line.
And this may be retired by then.
I would hope be be retired three or four.
I mean,
I think he's 39 now,
right,
Michael?
Uh,
yeah.
I might not be that old.
I might be,
I might be a up in them up a bit.
36 it might be (373) 063-0730 seven I don't think he has three years left.
Well,
he might say,
look,
she's like,
God,
it's so fucking game.
You know,
Michael Bisbing does not have any extraordinary physical attributes and not that
he's not a great athlete.
He certainly is not.
He's done a very good fighter.
He certainly is,
but cardio.
But if you look at a guy like rumble,
extraordinary physical attributes,
John Linacre,
extraordinary physical attributes.
Well Michael Bisping has is just toughness.
Just game as Foc,
toughness,
knock 'em out.
He comes back and he just keeps coming back.
There's no quit and there's not any,
is great.
Cardio is no quick,
amazing cardio.
Ryan Parson says in the gym,
he said he's never seen a guy that hates getting tapped and hates losing more
exchanges more.
I've never seen anything like it.
Even even just,
you know how you do like your normal warm up,
like if you're doing under hook,
just he's going 100% nonstop.
Like how the foot that slowed down on him.
The title man fucking title.
He's a hall of fame.
Better and better.
Even watch him improve.
Fight to fight his boxing,
his boxing's ridiculous man.
It's [inaudible] Silva knocked out Rockhold Luke Rockhold Lotoja disdainful in
that fight.
Like,
like,
come on man.
What are you gonna get pissed.
Yeah,
he's busy.
It's show up for that flood.
Yeah.
He was like disdainful that that was his challenge.
He got marked.
Oh and Bisbing was shooting triple x 19 in Toronto was like,
AH,
yeah,
I'll be down in four days to swirl champ.
What a great fucking story.
It's the best for 10 years.
Best store.
I fucking love.
Bisbing and then beats Dan Henderson in a close decision for this talk was all
fucking fight.
You forget about that fight when we talk about fights of the year.
Oh yeah.
That fight was so good.
So good.
And again,
his cardio.
Yeah,
he got he,
he landed h bomb twice.
Yeah,
landed it that Zombie Mod back and just start fucking boxing.
That's fucking crazy.
Got nothing but hard.
That much harder to tell you something.
I had a funny feeling about Luke Rockhold.
Luke was taking it seriously.
I didn't that you think your days and I'm like this.
He already beat them as being too for fucking years.
All he needs is one shot,
but business name a knockout artists like the bedding art for him to knock Luke
Rockhold on the first round.
I don't have no,
let me tell you something.
If my daughter catches you in one of those swinging overhand punches and clips
that tip your chin,
you got a problem.
Hey Brian.
Brian told me he would just new blocks in gym and the guys that came mind if
this girl,
he's going to kill me for telling the story.
You might have this girl jumps in there and swap some rounds and Brian's like,
sure.
He starts to move around.
This bitch is dead serious and shit's him with the right hand.
Brian was like,
Oh shit.
He said he's like a little wobble.
I'm like,
Bro,
if anyone catches you flush man.
Yeah,
you mean for a long night?
But actually the point of the Chan,
the way La Rockhold caught and Bisbing Bisbing swung it over the shoulder.
It was a beautiful left hook.
He stepped in with it and just whipped it over the top.
And it was something that him and Perillo had seen in rock holds game per Lowe's
coach of the year.
Very good code.
Hands down coach of the year.
Very good.
Could be Tito teases coach.
He still is.
Yeah.
He worked with Bj.
He's worked with a lot of guys.
Bj,
uh,
Tito,
cris Cyborg and Michael Bisping.
He's a quiet guy in terms of what,
he's not out there trying to get a lot of publicity.
He's not a attention whore.
Is this an excellent boxing coach?
Really knows his shit.
Yeah.